president Trump's son-in-law and senior
adviser jared kushner is on his way to
Iraq officials in the White House and
Iraq confirmed the trip to CBS News
cushion is traveling ahead of the
president's meetings this week with
three foreign leaders including China's
president mr. Trump said in a weekend
interview that if China does not crack
down on North Korea's nuclear program
the United States would do it alone
major Garrett is at the White House
major good morning good morning
increasingly if it is a foreign policy
meeting or trip that President Trump
really cares about jared kushner is
going to be there what he lacks in
experience he more than makes up for in
trust and loyalty and that's made
kushner's foreign policy portfolio
larger than anyone elses in this new
White House senior advisor jared kushner
is making his unannounced visit to Iraq
with the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff General Joseph Dunford Dunford is
the principal military advisor to the
President and defense secretary Kushner
is not the first Trump administration
official to visit the country defense
secretary mattis made an unannounced
trip to Iraq in February president Trump
has repeatedly leaned on his son-in-law
to shape the administration's foreign
policy your soldiers are fighting hard
kushner was at the table last month when
President Trump met with the Iraqi Prime
Minister at the White House the
president has tasked Kushner to help
broker a peace deal between Israel and
the Palestinians and he has been front
and center during visits by the Israeli
and Japanese Prime Minister's he trusts
his son in line I need a mcbryde former
chief of staff to Laura Bush says the 36
year old Kushner has broad influence his
expanding role is something that is
indicative of obviously the deep level
of trust that the president puts in him
to be an innovator and to come up with
different ideas this week mr. Trump will
meet with three foreign leaders
beginning this morning with Egyptian
president Abdel Fattah al-sisi then
Jordan's King Abdullah on Wednesday and
Chinese President jeje paying on
Thursday and Friday at mar-a-lago a 25
hour long summit that Kushner has been
shaping
recent North Korean provocations will be
at the center of talks with China in an
interview with the Financial Times
president Trump said quote if China is
not going to solve North Korea we will
Kushner's Rowland domestic policy is
substantial as well he's been known to
run economic meetings convened by the
president speaking largely while the
president looks on approvingly his wife
Ivanka also a domestic policy force
within this White House and on Friday
according to financial disclosure forms
released by the White House the two have
combined assets between 240 million and
714 million dollars both Nora remained
beneficiaries of their real estate and
investment businesses all right major
thank you so much